there is plenty concerned about how the
coronavirus may affect the overall
economy but the travel industry is
already feeling a seismic impact
businesses have been cancelling
conferences and restricting company
travel and cruise lines hotels and
airlines are seeing demand plummet here
to tell us about that impact and what to
be aware of if you're traveling is
Jessie Ashlock u.s. editor at Conde Nast
Traveler Jessie good morning good
morning good to be with you I'm clearly
a major impact across the travel
industry right now is there a comparable
event in modern times that you've seen I
think that you know this kind of
epidemic is unprecedented
however the closest thing that I would
point to is the immediate days after
September 11th I think there was so much
uncertainty about what was gonna happen
next there are a lot of people who
wondered if it might be the first of a
series of attacks and people were just
scared to fly and it revolves around
that uncertainty I think the word
uncertainty is really important to point
to here it's what's affecting the
markets and it's also what's affecting
travelers choices with the spread to 80
countries including the United States I
mean the question Jeff just posed you
know he has a cruise coming up you know
what are the cancellation policies and
how accommodating are these businesses
they are so lenient right now the the
whole industry is bending over backwards
to you know make it okay for their
client base because they know how
important the people who use their
services are for them in the long term
and they're willing to take a short-term
hit to make people feel comfortable
traveling in the future I think that you
know you've seen it with JetBlue United
all the airlines but especially with the
cruise industry which has probably you
know taken the biggest PR hit as a
result of this and the cruise industry
multiple cruise companies are offering
these incredibly lenient we've never
seen them before they were doing is
they're basically saying you will give
you a credit for the exact same credit
back for any trip within 15 or 18 months
precisely and that's happening with with
Royal Caribbean I think you were just
talking about Disney and and I think
we'll see we'll see that for a while and
we might see other stuff like incentives
to get people cruising again once
there's more certainty about you know
where we're headed I think in addition
to that it's worth pointing out you know
the really really comprehensive
pre-screening that the cruise companies
doing the flexibility with the
itineraries and I I wanted to take a
moment to like salute these people
because I feel like they get a lot of
guff you know it's like it's
inconvenient for travellers and
travelers hate to be inconvenience but
this is a really really tough situation
and you know you might just have to
spend an hour waiting for the next fight
the next representative to help you out
but they will come and they will help
you you know Jeff has something planned
my mom has a couple trips coming up we
were talking about this last night
because she was trying to get the most
up-to-date information because there is
uncertainty so where can people go to
make sure that they're up to date I mean
I think you know communicate with your
with your airline I think communicate
with your travel advisor if you're
booking a trip through a travel advisor
which we highly recommend doing a
contest traveler because these are the
unicorns who know everything and can
help you with everything and they have
the most up-to-date information about
everything certainly follow what the CDC
and State Department the World Health
Organization are saying and take it
seriously
but I also want to say like every but
every traveler is different and every
traveler has to make their own decisions
based on who they are where they're
going what their age and health are but
don't be afraid to travel what is the
long-term impact I think we don't know
yet but I do think that the travel
industry has proven itself to be
incredibly resilient and I think that
they're prepared as much as one can be
for events like this the most important
thing is that once there's more
certainty about what's going to happen
with all this people start traveling
again all right Jesse Ashlock thank you